prod showing some good signs as well i
know that some of you are are involved
in these trades so i want to share with
you guys my view here
and and see what can happen next so
is everything working fine first let me
quickly check
all right
we good here
looks like everything is working let me
just quickly announced
in the discord that i'm live
give me one sec sorry about that but
hey morning kevin hi
all right yes so just please let me know
hey brother if there is any issue with
the sound or the image as i'm having
some issues i had some issues last time
so just let me know i'm keeping an eye
on the tr on the on the chat
and i'm starting so as usual guys we
start with the big boys let's start with
amc
um
so what is happening here we are in a
triangle so you guys probably know that
but what is not that easy in this
triangle
um is to have the
good upper band all right so
to get the good upper band you need to
check what is giving you the best
reactions and you can't ignore the
recent past so at the beginning as some
of you know i was having a trendline
like this and i was here having this
breakout that only lasts three hours as
i showed you guys already in some other
videos cool bro the sound is perfect i'm
glad to hear that
and then here uh we got rejected
so
you need from then to take into account
this new high so i moved my trend line
like this
and then i need to take into account
this high because i like to use highs
and then you need to find what is
feeling the best you're just you know
checking and if we do like this we
connect this one which is which is of
course very important at 52.8
and we connect this one so to me the
streamline looks good we can even go
slightly lower it doesn't change much
okay and here i need to connect well as
well
all right so we're having something like
this
and this is our new trend line all right
so from here we can see that the two
pass days uh we are making a few
attempts on
on this trend line again we are trying
to break out so this is good what we
like to see before breakouts guys very
important so there is the volume that we
need to check also there needs to be a
nice consolidation just below the
breakout area
this is the setup that to me makes a
breakout perfect so
here um what do we have let's zoom in a
little bit not yet let's stay like that
so here we are only starting to
consolidate below this breakout level so
the breakout level is for me so going
lower so right now it's 44 all right
just like it was one week ago even if i
move the trend line because this is a
downward sloping trend line so
we need to close above 44 but it's good
if we take some energy if to check if
the market has energy that two things
you can do you can check the rsi okay
it's the first information we are right
now having a daily rsi at 55
so it's not overbought so it's good
enough for me for breakout and you can
check the bollinger bands it's something
i'm checking more and more because it's
i mean usually i'm checking those
consolidations visually and whenever i
see that the price action is steady i'm
happy but uh you can use the bullish
events that are an indicator that is
built for this right so let's use it and
here we can see that the bollinger bands
they were wide they were tight here why
they were tight because look we were
having
seven days in a row close to the 37 38
level so right now it's been only two
days we are around 42 so i would like to
see the price action staying at this
level all i mean if we break out it's
even better but if we don't break out i
don't want to see the price action
coming to back to 37 which would be fine
and would be actually a nice buying
opportunity
but um if we have this consolidation
like a few more days at 42 it's perfect
as well so just be aware that this is to
me the best setup that could happen i
get rid of those bollinger bands because
they're a bit ugly on the chart but they
are giving very precious information so
what can happen from here like i said
guys we were i think we'll probably
consolidate just below this would be the
perfect situation and if we get rejected
we're probably gonna find support there
so i think that the breakout is not
happening today or tomorrow but rather
next week this is my view once again
because we need to consolidate a bit
more and once the breakout happens then
we need to close a full day above 44
even better above 45 because it's the
new high 45 46 but above 44 would be um
if we spend the full day above 44 it
would be the first time it happens in a
long time i mean above this upper band
triangle upper band so it will be the
signal that we're standing five waves up
so we can expect once this breakout
happens so this is my preferred scenario
we stay here a little bit we break out
we retest and then we move into five
waves uh to the 130 level i think that
we are close to this scenario guys i'm
calling for it for uh quite some time uh
of course i was also signaling whenever
we had something that was looking like
we're correcting more but right now i
think that the correction is almost over
and that nice things are gonna come
let's check hey brother how are you
let's check quickly guys uh the
synthetic short you know it's something
that i like to check i'm personally very
um careful i mean i pay a lot of
attention to what is happening on the
145 strike we were last time at
19.98 million shares equivalent
so this is a good indicator for me to
monitor
and pa yes we
are above 20 million now and the dtc was
stable all right 350 was 355 345 stable
dtc okay but look at the 145 strike
20.3 million equivalent shares sitting
there this is something that would
probably um push option market makers to
be buyers on the upside so it's great to
see that
okay
so
um i'm pretty done on the amc guys if
you have any questions just ask me in
the chat i'm just gonna
be focused today on amc gme bln kn
um
and which one
and p r o g i was in the straight i got
out uh but i know that some of you are
still in and are asking me questions so
i want to answer these questions as good
as i can
um
let's do gme right now so the situation
is a little bit the same guys you know
that uh i'm making this update right now
because i think that this is looking
quite good so the big picture is the
same guys we are in a huge triangle the
difference uh between jamie and amc is
that amc uh gme sorry actually broke out
a few hours above this trend line
in a very impulsive way so this is good
right we like to see this kind of
behavior before breakout
it's you know just scaring the bears
it's showing that something is happening
it's creating volume it's bringing
attention to this stock which is what we
want guys the more people involved the
better it is
so
um so i like to see that then what
happened we have actually the kind of
pattern that we like to have which is
this kind of you know consideration then
we got a little bit rejected but look
guys we didn't even reach the 20-day
moving average when we don't reach those
support levels that are usually um you
know used by bears as targets is it's
good it means that bears are not able to
reach the targets so it's positive for
the press action and we got then this uh
yesterday this nice run up so let's
analyze what happened here but just
before analyzing i can already tell you
guys that this trend line is going lower
and we just got rejected you know close
to it so same thing here guys um um
yes
i'm going to keep it in english brother
but happy to see some french
guys here watching this video so for
jamie we need to have um the breakout
before it was 230 but it's going lower
and this is the good thing about being
in those triangles is that the breakout
level is going lower with us so there is
no rush i mean
uh of course it's better to be already
in which i am but if you're not and if
you want to get in
it's better to wait for the breakout
because the breakout is going lower so
the longer you wait the better it is and
here um
we tested this trendline uh
it's been one two three four times guys
in the past two weeks so it's good the
more a trend line is tested the weaker
it gets so here we are bullish guys but
let's be honest there is still an
alternative scenario where we find more
support 180 190 i don't know guys i
don't know what i know is that bulls are
uh attacking relentlessly the bear camp
which is good and if we do have this
breakout guys we would be in the same
situation as amc we would probably uh
strongly move higher so the question is
where for example so right now i think
we are in the second wave
so it would be a third wave guys some
people uh some of you guys were asking
me where this move could uh go
and
i would say 340 right away i mean this
is a third wave this is impulsive
and yes i think that this move would
make sense all right around 60 maybe in
two or three days like plus 20 plus 40
or something like this this would make
sense then probably some taking you know
some uh taking profits would happen here
and we would do four and five uh i have
a target of
but as you guys um maybe heard last time
i am moving a little bit uh my target i
see a question about amc i'm gonna
answer to it right away did i miss amc
bro you didn't miss anything because as
you can see we still
are below this we are still a corrective
pattern so it's time to buy any time i
would personally be not financial advice
i would personally be a buyer at 3
8 37 i would add more even higher now
okay i would need to check but around 37
38 i would uh add up to my position for
sure
um let's go back to jme so i was saying
you guys know that my target is 800.
it's a target that i have for a very
long time
that i believe in but when i check the
option market guys um
let's have a look
okay
some of you asking me for tesla i can
have a look as well
all right so jme guys first thing then
so you can see the dtc is higher here we
are at five guys
that's great
okay it's one of the highest i've seen
because you see gme we were at 502 okay
we are stable at five okay
we were even at six early november but
before that before that it was three so
we are right now let me
just keep gme
it's important to check that guys
because it's giving you the levels of
dtc that creates those strong moves up
when was the last time we had a strong
move up
on the 3rd of november all right what
was the dtc on the 3rd of november 6
okay so whenever we are close to 5 above
5
those kind of strong moves can happen
because shorts are panicking and they
are covering their position so five is a
level where this could happen again so
that this is the reason why i like to
see those strong moves because it's
showing that there is a lot of tension
so it's pretty good
so um and yeah let me just quickly show
you that again we are monitoring the 950
strike
not moving uh for still
400.07 million shares coming mostly from
the jan 22 maturity so
nothing very new guys i just wanted to
make this update to um
to show you that what is happening right
now is good whenever we consolidate
close to the breakout and we're testing
it many times it's good which doesn't
mean that it will break out this week i
rather think it might happen next week
um
because we need to consider it a little
bit more but this would make sense and
once again you guys know that uh i'm
talking that three of the two strong
moves that happened on amc and gamestop
got triggered when the spy uh
moved strongly lower and right now very
quickly guys i'm giving you my view
again on the spy
um i'm still bullish i think we are in
this third wave in yellow and that we
can push a little bit higher before
correcting so maybe this would go
together as it did in the past maybe we
will see the global market tanking by
two percent or something like this and
some margin calls triggering uh amc and
gme strong moves up maybe you know this
is just a theory but a theory that has
been proven in the past so
you know i just like to keep an eye on
those things let me quickly have a look
guys
at your questions and give me more likes
guys only 10 likes come on you can do
better guys
so what do we have morning morning
brother
okay
is prague finished so prague is in this
video i want to talk about it of course
when would jimmy get to 3 15
uh i hope next week
um
let's say all right maybe 10 days i
don't know it would depend on
how long we uh we are able i mean if we
stay
three more days at this level
it would happen anytime if we get
rejected then you know it's the same
thing we need to build up again this
boot camp right below the breakout area
so you know to build a boot camp you you
cannot only
spend two or three days below the
bracket you need one week 10 days so
right now this is what we're doing all
right one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten i don't know if i can
count those three to be honest they're a
bit low
so it's not very easy to say if it's
five days ten days let's check the
bollinger bands quickly
ah 22 likes better guys thank you
bollinger bands
still wide look
they are wide they are wide why because
there is this strong move up that
created a lot of volatility the
bollinger bands are computed uh on the
20-day moving average and take then we
take twice the volatility to create the
upper band and the lower band
from the 20-day moving average so there
are 20 trading days so this one two
three
you see so basically it means that we
would need to wait
at least
five or ten more training days so it's
one or two weeks all right so this is
the answer given by bollinger bands i
would personally just say you know
visually that we don't need that much
time i think that a few more days just
close to this breakout area would be
enough to scare the bells and to uh
create the breakout and the strong move
up that would probably follow so hope i
answered the question well
okay cool guys so
let's
now
do
bln k okay you asked for prog i give you
prog first p prog
that makes sense so prog
interesting one so let me quickly for
those who so this is a healthcare stock
let's check if i can find more
information quickly
health care testing the company offers
complex molecular diagnostic solutions
mmm complex all right protein t service
customers in the united states all right
i like everything that is complex you
know everything that is molecular it
sounds good it sounds like you know it
maybe has a greater potential that the
usual uh healthcare companies i don't
know but uh what i know is that
technically we are bullish all right so
let me go through the price action here
there are too many lines let's get rid
of those but those lines tho were those
that i was using that i was using
uh when i was in the stream i got out i
took profits but uh
it's not over so let's analyze
okay now i'm changing a bit my trend
line you see
this one is great okay
uh so what do we have guys we have so
did you see that what i just did you
know i updated this trendline the
previous one was very useful as well it
was here but there is a new one so we
need to use it look this one break out
here break out on that day with volume
retested we go higher okay that's over
that's behind us right now what do we
have the same thing
trend line
now i cannot make any other flat more
flat trend lines so it's the last one
and we broke it we broke it we retested
it around three i personally
took profits around 350.
um okay at that time it was not looking
i mean that bullish now it's uh better
so what do we have we completed one two
three all right with with the third wave
that usually goes beyond some
major levels so this is what happened
here then we corrected in what looks to
be what seems to be a force wave all
right so let's measure
how usually force waves they go to the
38.2 retracement
and tara 38.2 roughly below all right so
here it would be a nice opportunity to
buy i didn't see the streamline at that
time you know
if i had seen it i would have probably
uh tried something here but you know too
many stocks i was buying the lnk
so you cannot be everywhere and
we then had
this breakout that tells me so this was
two days ago and that tells me that we
are in an ongoing fifth wave so the
question you have is a very good
question is it over so let's be honest i
don't know but i can try to answer to
answer that i'm gonna measure one plus
three first thing apply to the bottom of
the force and check the ratios you guys
know because i'm telling you that that
all the time that usually uh fifth wave
they go to the open 618 one two one or
one two one point six one eight
relationship uh
i mean from one plus three applied to
the bottom of the force which i'm doing
here so the first level is
five point fifteen we went above okay
then 660 we didn't reach it and the next
one is
nine all right so it gives us three
levels uh we have already reached the
first one so maybe
the fifth wave is over okay first
information
now i'm gonna go on a shorter time frame
to get more information but maybe this
is over i'm gonna check the option
market because the option market
is telling you where is the gamma so
when you know for example if you have a
lot of gamma if i see i don't know what
i'm gonna find but if i see a lot of
gamma around
seven
it tells me
that we might very well go above
seven quickly
and if the gamma is more at five
i would say that
it might be done alright so let's check
if we have more gamma at five or more
gamma at seven
okay
okay so many information guys here many
information so let me go with you
through this information so first we
have more gamma at seven than we have at
five okay first so this is rather
bullish this is rather telling me that
we have some energy on the option market
to push higher first information second
information is that the dtc despite the
very big synthetic short and regular
short
because we are having right now uh 50 of
total short interest
but
the daily volume is that big guys that
the dtc is only 0.3 what does it mean it
means that shorts are not under pressure
so they can buy but they can just keep
the shock positions and think all right
i don't care i keep the short position
i'm gonna bite late i'm gonna buy later
lower they are not under pressure so
whenever they are not under pressure
whenever the dtc is small the option
market has a lesser impact on the price
action so here i have more gamma at
seven but
as the dtc is that low
i cannot really take this into account
in my analysis so i'm gonna try
something else the other tools what do
we have we can check first on the daily
time frame okay overbought rsi but it
has been overbought for a long time we
still pushed higher so this is not a
good
reason
uh i'm gonna
have a look at the moving averages let's
go right away to the hourly time frame
guys it's the best time frame uh for
this kind of moves and here
okay we broke it so basically below five
it's not looking any more like the fifth
is on so it looks a bit like the fifth
is complete
um because we broke this 20 hours moving
average this is a basic method that is
working very well
i mean it's the best i have um
you can always then adapt and change it
a bit but basically using the 20 hours
simple moving average on
most of the moves up
uh is a good
indicator of
uh to know if the move is still on or
not and here we are below so it's not
great let's be honest
so i don't have that more tools i can
show you guys and use to know if it's
over or not
you know we have some reasons to think
it can go higher some reason to think
that it might be over so i would come
back to the daily time frame take a step
back
uh
and just
what else can we do now we are wondering
if this move is complete or not here we
have the 20-day moving average that has
been broken and we still went higher so
it's not a very good indicator anymore
um
we don't have that many tools guys
you know i'm neutral here everything can
happen uh if we trade below four it
would it would of course not look good
because it was the breakout level so it
has not been retested yet so we might
very well come quickly here and push
higher but
let's be honest if we close the day
lower today it looks more like um
like this is done and then what can we
have on the longer run guys this might
be only the first and then second all
right this is possible as well but this
would depend a lot on the fundamentals
of the company uh on you know it it
doesn't depend of course only on
technicals anymore but this looks
impulsive this looks like a first wave
um so let's see let's see i'm quite
neutral right now on prog i hope i
answered well it took me some time but
you know
many things to say
sorry just give me one second
all right i'm back i'm here
so let me quickly have a look at the
questions uh
let me show you bl nk
quickly okay bielen catuda moon all
right so
i pretty much agree with that so this
was some information breakout was a big
value
okay i'm writing guys uh course and i'm
using the examples
uh many examples some of them are some
trades that i've been doing uh to
explain the setups that we are looking
for all right so
what is the situation on bln k guys so
basically we had this massive run up all
right that developed in five waves
okay then we corrected
doing some kind of an abc okay and now
we have we have the breakouts so uh i
entered my position around the breakout
level here all right around 32 35 i
don't remember something like this and
right now
what is the situation
so let me get rid of all of that
all right so it looks very good to me
it's very impulsive
the volume is only starting we had the
earnings
not long ago that helped push higher
um
[Music]
i'm personally
so what is this company doing they are
basically doing batteries and you guys
know if you are following a bit the
sector of eevee that this is the main
issues that most of um ev owners have is
where do i charge my uh car and you know
those uh companies that are older than
vlnk they are trying to find the best
technology to do it so i mean if they
manage to do it this can have a very big
uh
impact on the price action and we can
reach some crazy levels so this is what
i'm targeting personally on bl nk now
technically
technically guys we are good the recent
high of the down
of the downtrend that i was using here
is at
40
44 roughly so we are on it guys we are
consolidating just above which is good
uh
the rsi is a little bit of a boat but
you know when those strong moves happen
it can uh remain overbought and push
higher
um
[Music]
i don't really know when the pullback
will happen we would probably develop
into five waves so one two i think we
are still in the third wave
i think we are we're doing something
like this this is what i hope uh i would
personally um take a little bit more
profits in the 50 60 area and then just
let it run
um
what else can we say here yeah it's i
mean not nothing else to say this is
bullish we might have a pullback but it
would probably be both
we have this breakout i believe the
market developed in waves and i believe
this is a new wave that has just started
that will last for six months so i'm
bullish on this stock let's check
quickly what the option market is giving
us i cannot retrieve options here but
even without retrieving options guys
look what i can have
okay so without options we are at uh
35 of regular shoot interest so i guess
you can double that
with the options i don't know somehow my
spreadsheet is not working for the lnk
and the ddc is at three so we can double
that so we have a dtc around six i guess
uh taking into account the synthetic
short so this is a squeeze situation
guys alright so this is the reason why i
think that this move can just skyrocket
and once again everything looks good to
me in terms of technicals and um and
fundamentals
okay
okay
so let me have a look guys at your
questions
oh right
right dramatist
yes i come from paris bro exactly
i mean i was born in paris then i moved
to chambery this is basically where i'm
gonna be back by the way next week in
two weeks i'm moving from hong kong guys
coming back to france for a few months
then i go to dubai
but let's do things step by step i'm
gonna be in france i'm gonna be closer
to um
to the time to your time zone so i'm
gonna do more live sessions i will be
taking positions live as well i think
it's gonna be very interesting for you
to watch that for me it's gonna be very
exciting too
um so i'm yeah i'm very excited about
that and let me check what other
questions you guys have
can you check the groupon okay i'm gonna
check groupon
question about a hidden bullish
divergence on gme so let's try to find
it for less time frame
okay so basically a bullish hidden
divergence is whenever the price action
is making higher lows
on a momentum that is shifting lower
that is making lower lows so we are
looking for that
and
here the momentum is making higher
lows i don't see the bullish hidden
divergence bro there is not any on the
first time frame and jamie bullish
hidden divergence once again is whenever
the market is making lower low the
momentum sorry is making lower lows and
the marking making higher lows so here
the market is making higher lows but the
momentum is making lower
lows high lows as well
so this is there is no divergence i
don't see it let me know if i miss it
bro but i don't see any bullish
divergence on gm chart for hours
i use stocks up stochastic okay
i don't use that indicator a lot
sorry damn
okay indeed on the stochastic that's
true
okay
here the market is making indeed the
stochastic is making lower lows all
right but it's interesting to see that
we have the hidden buddhist divergence
on the stochastic but we don't have it
on the rsi we don't have it on the macd
so it's not that powerful but it's still
one more information that is interesting
to keep in mind
and i personally don't use stochastic
divergences so i won't be able to say if
it's a very trustful
signal or not but it's here
and it's just one more information to
add to all the other bullish signals
that we have
questions about exit prices but guys um
you know
i think that taking some profits
um it depends how you want to play it i
would personally
maybe buy a little bit of protection
around 340 like buying a food i would
keep my calls basically i'm not selling
anything on the upside but i might buy
some protection around 340 on gme
and on amc i didn't check guys but maybe
around 52 okay because this is where we
might have the next pullback right so if
you want to swing
um 52 is a level you can you can buy
some short term put to just sell it
right away uh afterwards
uh and let's do things step by step but
the real target is higher is like 135 on
amc 800 gme even higher than that guys
this is what i was showing to you on gme
we have a massive
number of options on the 950 strike so
that means that we might go beyond that
right so i would need to update my
target at some point for now i'm keeping
800 because you know it's it's my target
and i want it to be reached but whenever
it's gonna be reached i'm gonna update
my target if it needs to be updated and
i can tell you that i would be using all
the information i have and the first
information i would be using guys is
this
sorry bam okay
950 massive massive massive number of
options so it's very likely we go beyond
it
um
like maybe one thousand one hundred one
thousand two hundred so let's discuss
this if we go to 800 first
okay
so what time is it i have 10 minutes
left with you guys i'm gonna be quick
give me more likes guys click on this
like button
okay so what do i have
dbag wkhs
i just checked prague
brother
am i rich yet
soon soon
okay what date and strike looks good for
blnke if you are not in the lnk yet to
be honest
i mean not financial advice but
it's hard to buy now you know if you are
in lower it's good to keep your position
but
there might be a pullback right this is
a stock market a pullback can happen
anytime so i think that the good strike
is uh you know something like i'm
personally long the gen 2250 strike i
think it's the good one uh going to the
70 is a bit risky especially now but if
there is a pullback i don't know to the
35 area going to the 50 on gen 32 i
think is the good thing otherwise maybe
the 70 strike would give it a bit more
time i don't like to buy this very high
strike
high strikes especially when the market
is moving that strongly you're gonna pay
a very huge premium for the volatility
so
i won't you know it wouldn't be a good
um thing to say that is the right time
to buy those uh high strike calls so
lower a bit the strike and wait maybe
for a pullback
okay i can do lucid i was following
lucid
uh
some of you a lot of you are asking me
this one so let's do
let's see all right so
the question you guys have is can we go
higher and i was trying to answer this
question yesterday i almost took a short
position here on lucid i didn't get in
um and the reason why i didn't get in so
first we can do the elliott wave
analysis one two three four five measure
one plus three
applied to the bottom of the fourth as
we
always do guys bam
okay and this is giving me 64 is the
1.618 which is also the all-time high so
64 is from a level i want you to take a
short position to play the move down so
i think we might go there all right we
are kind of neutral between 50 and 52
and 64. but we are in this area that
this is now support i think we might
reach this level okay this is only a
feeling um
what can you use maybe here the 20 hours
moving average now it's not giving great
signals
okay i don't know if you go to 264 but
if we go there uh this is the reason why
i didn't take a short position there and
maybe other
bears might do the same
because
look at that guys
basically the option market grew a lot
since
i started to make analysis on this stock
and right now we are
we have a lot of options on the 70
strike and on the
90 strike right so those two strikes
that grew a lot are telling me that
investors are believing in a higher move
uh and this can create maybe something
that goes to the 90 area all right so
this is possible um
it's hard to say
what level we would reach before
correcting but my take is that at least
64 and why not seeing something even
higher
all
right does dodge looks like it's going
to break out
let me check
i haven't checked the dutch coin for
quite some time but i know that you guys
like this cryptocurrency so let's have a
look
break out i don't know i mean on the
dance side
i see some support at 22. first thing
i'm just doing some trendline work first
nothing very clean on the upside
we had here some kind of a fake out
so i'm not gonna keep that
okay no divergence
um
what about the volume
volume is going slightly lower
i don't know it looks it looks like 22
wants to hold all right
at first glance
um i would like to see us a more of a
sold rsi
here on the stream line to be a buyer
right this is a setup i like to trade
whenever we are coming on a trend line
with uh oversold rsi uh this is usually
giving a reaction here we come on the
treadland but the rsa is not oversold so
it's not perfect um
and i don't have any clean break trend
line on the upside that i could use
maybe this one is the best
and we have here the 200-day moving
average so i would say that guys as long
as we are you know below 28 on dodge
i don't see it strongly moving higher
whenever we break this
uh the volume might kick in and then
nice things can happen but uh very
quickly let me show you bitcoin guys
this goes together
and
i'm not so bullish on bitcoin right now
guys since we broke from this wedge okay
at sixty three thousand uh i was already
telling you uh last week that we have
this bearish divergence that appeared i
was still believing that we might push
higher uh despite this bearish
divergence just like we had before in
the past here we had the british
divergence you can see macd lower rsi
lower price action higher and we still
had the last move up so i was hoping
we'd get this last move up which we
didn't we broke on the downside from the
wedge pattern so right now um i'm
telling you about uh telling you about
the bitcoin because this is either is
it's just the same thing as analyzing
jamie and amc when you're talking about
the meme movement and when you talk
about crypto you check the bitcoin all
right it's everything gonna follow this
uh and right now to me we started a
correction
uh after we broke 63 000 i'm personally
still long i didn't manage to exit here
because i was sleeping
and i don't want to use any stop loss on
the bitcoin so i'm just gonna try to
exit my position on a b wave all right
around 62 63 000 uh we have not
completed the a wave yet so maybe we're
gonna go lower we can see that we find
some support on a 20-day moving average
that is right now at 59 500 we are right
on it so we are testing it
uh so let's see if this holds but if you
even if it breaks we're gonna have a b
wave coming at some point and i think a
c wave as well so i think we have two
maybe three weeks uh left on the bitcoin
before uh going higher and my scenario
is that we correct the move down so we
go higher a little bit 62 63 we get
rejected and then we push higher
what target do we have for the bottom uh
the natural level is the
bottom of the fourth wave whenever we
correct a five moves five waves move up
we usually go to the bottom of the force
which is here fifty seven 000 so if i
managed to sell i would be a buyer there
otherwise i would just keep my position
and 57 000 is also the 38.2 retracement
of the third wave and you guys know that
foss waves likes to go to the 38.2
percent retracement so it's uh giving us
a double signal a double support level
at 57 000. so i believe that uh there's
going to be a strong buying power coming
here but if we go there right away
before making the b wave this would tell
me
that either we do a flat okay possible
so this is another scenario
or we do a deeper zigzag okay
and this information would be given it's
truly to say it would be given here guys
if we do the b wave and then we go below
the a wave it's not a flat anymore it's
a zigzag and then we'll probably go to
the 54 000 level and if the b wave goes
above 64 000
uh it might be as well good news for a
flat correction all right
because if we here we reach even 67 or
something like this
uh
it would tell us that the support would
go higher so the higher the b wave the
higher the bottom of the c wave so it's
some information that we don't have yet
and that i will try to share with you as
soon as i have it
but for now we are correcting i think we
have three weeks of correction ahead of
us
okay guys
five more minutes i do one more and okay
uh groupon it has been asked the first
adam brother i'm doing it for you so
here we go grpn
okay
so it's a stock i've been following for
quite some time
so you guys know what they do groupon so
the the sector is not amazing let's be
honest
uh
that this is the reason why you know
they had this massive downtrend
and we we're not bullish on the long
term we would be bullish only if we go
above 32 33 uh but there is a nice setup
on the short term because we are above
the moving averages
we had here the earnings
okay on the 4th of november that
probably had to push higher
we had this i don't see the volume
we had this breakout with high volume so
since then we are bullish to me
and i think we might go to the 32 level
to test it so i would personally be
taking some profits there
okay and then let's see if we are able
to do this or not but for now we are
bullish we might retest as well the 25
level we retested it once we might
retest it again to find some more energy
so it's possible as well but we are
bullish on the short term on the very
short term we are slightly bearish okay
let's be honest
um
but
i mean this is looking great on the for
the coming month uh if we do trade below
25 it's not looking great anymore so
this is the reason why i personally have
a stop loss just below that level and
i'm targeting 32 i'll probably take 50
of my um profits here and leave the
other uh 50
run if something happens
so i'm checking the questions one more
time quickly guys but i need to
prepare for the open i need to make some
calls
okay guys that's it for me so have a
great day stay safe um thank you very
much for watching this video i'm gonna
make the usual weekly weekend update of
course on amc and gamestop and you know
i'm just here i'm around post in the
comment if there is something you want
me to analyze i'm gonna have a look at
that thank you so much for watching guys
and i see you soon cheers